l'albanie kempson c'est vrai mais un
truc à dire al yom
denis voilà pour la suite de sa carrière
en tulle et est ce que l'artiste il est
parti - l'artiste est parti j'étais dans
le coup mes enfants et je leur les
doigts mais j'en ai marre quoi depuis
juillet on m'appelle chocolat chaud que
je suis pas jazzy mire
[Applaudissements]
oui ahmed démontent une question bien le
continent même élan ce moment il est en
tournage avec les réalisateurs on
embrasse aussi olivier nakache et eric
toledano qui avait bien sûr intouchable
et vous êtes en tournage en ce moment de
quoi dans ce cas pas tardé à bercy quand
vous dire tout de suite c'est un pote
annonce une voyelle par le goût de la
bagarre
oui merci c'est vraiment un truc à dire
ayoub denis pas là pour la suite de sa
carrière
on tue les voulait conviendra petit
extrait du spectacle
ah oui c'est bien on en a parlé c'est
notre dernière pour eux c'est notre
dernière promo donc j'espère que ça nous
portera chance mais c'est sûr et et
vraiment je voulais rendre hommage à
alban puisque est vraiment dans le film
il est extraordinaire aux ronds et 2
vous êtes et il a une douceur et un truc
hyper tous sont dans le regard ce qui
fait que toutes ces conneries mais bon
le kiff malgré tout est vraiment ça m'a
mis là
[Musique]
messieurs du point
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]